EVERYONE IS LOOKING TO GET BACK
TO WORK AND BACK TO BUSINESS.
>>>> Ed: THANKS FOR STARTING US
OFF.
>> Sandra: FOR MORE ON ALL
THIS LET’S BRING IN TEXAS
SENATOR JOHN GORDON.
SENATOR, GOOD MORNING AND THANKS
FOR BEING HERE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> Sandra: ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
LET’S LOOK AT SOME OF THESE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE REOPENING IN
TEXAS ON FRIDAY.
RETAIL STORES, RESTAURANTS,
MOVIE THEATERS, LIBRARIES AND
EVEN MUSEUMS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS IS THE RIGHT
TIMING THAT TEXAS CAN REOPEN
SOME OF THE BUSINESSES AS SOON
AS THIS WEEK?
>> SANDRA, THERE IS NO PLAYBOOK
FOR THIS, IT’S UNPRECEDENTED.
I KNOW GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS
CONSULTING WITH THE BEST MINDS,
THE EXPERTS TO TRY TO GUIDE HIS
DECISION-MAKING.
BUT TO ME, THE KEY IS NOBODY IS
FORCED TO OPEN UP, BUT THEY CAN
GRADUALLY, SUBJECT TO THESE
GUIDELINES AND THEN WE WILL HAVE
THE PAUSE BUTTON AND SEE HOW
IT’S GOING BEFORE WE PROCEED TO
OPEN UP MORE.
BUT NOBODY BELIEVES WE CAN STAY
LOCKED DOWN AND HUNKERED DOWN IN
OUR HOMES AND ISOLATED FOREVER.
>> Sandra: AND OF COURSE WE
HEARD FROM GOVERNOR ABBOTT AS
WELL THAT WHILE SOME OF THOSE
BUSINESSES WILL REOPEN AND ALSO
THE MUSEUMS AND LIBRARIES,
SOCIAL DISTANCING MEASURES WILL
NEED TO CONTINUE TO TAKE PLACE.
THOSE OPERATIONS THAT WILL NOT
REOPEN OUR JAMS, BARBERSHOPS,
HAIR SALONS, BARS, TATTOO
PARLORS.
SO WHAT SENATOR CRITERIA DO YOU
THINK NEEDS TO BE MET IN ORDER
TO DECIDE, OKAY.
PHASE TWO.
LET’S START OPENING SOME OF
THESE OTHER BUSINESSES.
>> I BELIEVE THE REASON WE DID
THE INITIAL LOCKDOWN WAS
PRIMARILY TO PROTECT OUR
HOSPITALS FROM GETTING OVERRUN
WITH COVID-19 PATIENTS SO THEY
WERE TOLD NO ELECTIVE SURGERY,
YOU HAVE TO LEAVE YOUR BEDS OPEN
AND YOU HAVE TO LEAVE YOUR ICU
AVAILABLE AS WELL AS
VENTILATORS.
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE THESE
MITIGATION EFFORTS HAVE BENT THE
CURVE, I THINK THE GOVERNOR IS
WISELY AND OUR MAYORS ARE DOING
THE SAME THING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TRYING TO SEE.
OKAY.
CAN WE TAKE A FIRST STEP?
CAN WE STEP OUR BIG TOE IN THE
WATER AND SEE HOW THAT WORKS?
I THINK WE WILL BE GUIDED BY
WHAT THE EXPERIENCES AND WHAT
THE REACTION IS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC SAFETY COMES FIRST.
>> Sandra: AT NEXT, THE
QUESTION BECOMES SO SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO MAKE IT THROUGH THIS
THAT ARE CONTINUING TO STRUGGLE
AND ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT
HAVEN’T BEEN ABLE TO REOPEN OR
WON’T THIS WEEK.
HIS FOX BUSINESS.COM ARTICLE ON
STIMULUS PHASE FOUR.
YOU’VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT IT, THE
CORONAVIRUS STIMULUS PHASE FOUR
COULD EXCEED $1 TRILLION AND
INCLUDE NEGATIVE PAYROLL TAX.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THAT AND DO YOU THINK IT HAS A
CHANCE AT PASSING CUSTOMER >>
SANDRA, I THINK IT’S PREMATURE
TO CONSIDER WHAT ADDITIONAL
STEPS WE MIGHT TAKE BECAUSE WE
JUST SPENT ROUGHLY $2.8 TRILLION
AND, AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT ANY
TIME TO DO ANYTHING BIG AND THIS
FAST, AND AGAIN, IT’S
UNPRECEDENTED, THERE WILL BE
SOME BUMPS AND SOME PROBLEMS.
WHAT I’D LIKE DO IS SEE HOW WELL
WHAT WE HAVE ALREADY DONE MEETS
THE NEED AND THEN BE GUIDED BY
WHAT WE LEARNED.
I THINK IT’S PREMATURE TO TALK
ABOUT A TRILLION DOLLARS MORE
ADDED TO THE NATIONAL DEBT.
>> Sandra: GOT IT.
MEANWHILE, MITCH McCONNELL HAS
BEEN GETTING SOME CRITICISM FOR
COMMENTS THAT HE MADE SUGGESTING
BANKRUPTCY FOR SOME STATES
RATHER THAN FEDERAL BAILOUTS.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO AGREEING WITH
THAT, QUESTIONING AND THE TWEET,
WHY WOULD WE BAIL OUT SOME OF
THE STATES THAT WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING BEFORE THIS HIT?
GOVERNOR JAY INSLEE FROM
WASHINGTON IS THE LATEST TO
CRITICIZE THAT SUGGESTION FROM
MITCH McCONNELL.
LET’S LISTEN TOGETHER AND I’LL
GET YOUR REACTION.
>> WE ARE HOPING THAT CONGRESS
WILL ROUNDLY REJECT
SENATOR McCONNELL’S SUGGESTION
OF THE WAY TO DEAL WITH THIS IS
TO AND ALLOW STATES TO GO
BANKRUPT.
THAT’S THE MOST LUDICROUS IDEA
I’VE HEARD FOR A LONG, LONG TIME
TIME.
>> Sandra: SO SENATOR, WHAT
WAS YOUR REACTION TO THAT
SUGGESTION FROM
MITCH McCONNELL?
>> I THINK IT WAS LARGELY
UNFORTUNATELY MISINTERPRETED AND
WHAT SENATOR McCONNELL WAS
TRYING TO SAY OR HE DID SAY WAS
THAT THERE ARE LIMITS TO THE
EXTENT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CAN PAY THE BILLS FOR THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
STATES ARE SOVEREIGN.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN TAX BASE AND
THEIR OWN BUDGETS AND SOME
STATES WE KNOW ARE NOTORIOUSLY
BAD ABOUT NOT BALANCING THEIR
BUDGETS AND HAVING LARGE
UNFUNDED PUBLIC SECTOR UNION
PENSION PLANS FOR EXAMPLE.
WE ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO DO
WHAT’S NECESSARY TO DEAL WITH
THE VIRUS.
THIS IS AN EMERGENCY WHICH IS
WHY YOU SEE THIS UNPRECEDENTED
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR STATES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT AT SOME POINT WE WILL HAVE
TO HAVE A SERIOUS CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT THOSE LIMITS ARE
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CAN’T CONTINUE TO SPEND MONEY
AND ADD TO OUR NATIONAL DEBT AND
DEFICITS.
THAT IN IN AND OF ITSELF CAN CRE
A DANGEROUS SITUATION.
>> Sandra: THAT IS A DEBATE
THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO SEE
HEAT UP IN WASHINGTON.
AMONG OTHER THINGS, INCLUDING
POSSIBLE OTHER ROUND OF
STIMULUS, WE WILL WATCHING